the relationship between the quarian and
the geth is one of the main through
lines of the mass effect series
an analog for the broader theme of ai
servitude and
sapience by the time the events of the
first mass effect take place
the quarian are a downbeat nomadic
people living aboard a flotilla of ships
and the geth threatened to wipe out life
in the galaxy
on this week's episode of mass effect
lore let's start with the quarian or as
they're known to the geth
the creators and how they ended up
fighting for survival
against the very things they created for
more videos like this one and coverage
of the upcoming mass effect legendary
edition
make sure to like this video and
subscribe
the quarian home planet of ranoc is an
arid desert in the milky way
due to its dry nature and lack of
insects growing and cultivating food was
difficult but the whole planet wasn't
completely barren the southern continent
had
excellent farmland the quarian are a
technologically advanced race and used
their knowledge to create the geth
a subservient labor force designed to
help in fact
geth translates to servant of the people
in the quarian language of kellish
the citadel council had strict rules
prohibiting the creation of artificial
intelligence
so the geth were initially designed as a
virtual intelligence
but the quarian discovered that the get
they'd made weren't all that clever
over time they tinkered with the geth
and began to network them together
which enabled them to do more and more
complex tasks
while geth can't share sensory
information they can communicate with
each other at the speed of light
and share their processing power
shifting it to where it's needed
with a collective conscious of sorts
over time they began to gain
intelligence at a rapid rate
and were eventually capable of logic and
reason
the geth had evolved
one day a geth asked its overseer an
innocent but profound
question does this unit have a soul
terrified at the implications of the
question and perhaps the answer to it
the quarians ordered immediate
termination of the geth
not just the unit who asked the question
all of them but it was too late
in the beginning only some geth
retaliated merely to defend those units
who were unable to fight for themselves
but the quarians doggedly chased them
down even going so far as to declare
martial law
as well as imprison and kill their own
who were hiding death
by 1895 the two races were engaged in
all-out war
known throughout the galaxy as the geth
war but to the geth as
the morning war because of the shared
network geth don't really die
instead when one is terminated its
program is merely transmitted elsewhere
as a result the geth were victorious
within a year killing over 99
of the pre-walk warian population the
quarian who were left
fled the planet taking to space aboard
their ships
while the geth didn't follow the
quarians to space their troubles did
believing that the citadel council would
grant them aid the quarians pleaded for
help
only to be cast out and have their
embassy aboard the citadel closed
the reaction from the council seemed
over the top but the quarians had broken
one of the council's strictest laws
don't interfere with or create
artificial intelligence
their doom was of their own making and
now they were left to reckon with it on
their own
in the deep dark depths of space
life aboard the flotilla or migrant
fleet is far from easy
with no homeland or council help
resources are extremely scarce and the
quarians had to adapt to ensure the
survival of their species
the quarians have a weakened immune
system caused by their harsh homeland
and then
exacerbated by years spent aboard
sterile spaceships
so they each wear a special suit to
shield them from the outside world
their envirosuit the suit protects them
from infections that might otherwise
kill them
and if it gets ripped its automatic seal
compensates to mitigate the spread of
infection
despite receiving vaccinations against
various diseases throughout their lives
quarians are typically unwilling to
remove their suits
and if they do must undertake extreme
precautions first
which makes having relations difficult
in fact linking envirosuits with another
is one of the most
intimate things a quarian can do as it
carries huge risks even in sterile
environments
but it's not like the quarians are
getting down with it all the time either
there's actually a law prohibiting
having more than one child
unless the population is in decline
quarian society is built upon securing
the continuation of their species
they work together as a community more
frequently than other mass effect races
with young quarians undertaking a
pilgrimage when they come of age
in order to expand their horizons but
also to prove their worth to the fleet
by bringing back something useful
like technology information or resources
in order to prevent inbreeding upon
their return from their pilgrimage
newly anointed adult quarians choose a
brand new ship in the flotilla to live
and settle down on
presenting their new captain with
whatever they picked up on their travels
the quarians don't use credits the
regular currency used throughout the
galaxy
instead valuing food medicine and
technology
they keep a close eye on food and
medicine to ensure that there's enough
to go around
but they are freer with personal items
with limited space aboard the flotilla
and a lack of attachment to
things the quarian donate what they
don't want or need and others take it to
use
so nothing goes to waste the quarians
have a civilian government called the
conclave that makes the majority of
decisions for the fleet
and there is an admiralty board that
oversees them in the most serious
situations the admiralty board can
overturn a government decision
but once they've done so they must
either all quit their posts
or face being arrested as the fleet is
still technically under martial law from
the geth war
most issues never even make it to the
conclave and are handled by the ship's
captain
instead due to a lack of space aboard
the flotilla's ships
the worst criminals in society are
exiled because why waste resources on
those who aren't contributing
but that's just one of the many reasons
the rest of the galaxy is untrusting of
the quarians after creating the geth
exiling their worst prisoners as well as
their habit of moving through systems to
scavenge and mine whatever they can
they're often seen as second-class
citizens and thieves
but the quarians didn't want to be a
burden on the rest of their galaxy they
dreamt of retaking their homeworlds
but the quarian homeworlds weren't
exactly fully populated by the geth
after their rebellion
instead of building a civilization upon
ranuk the geth chose to live in computer
hubs aboard spaceships
monitoring the extranet for any
information they could use and opening
fire upon any ships that came near them
while the geth kept tabs on the rest of
the galaxy they preferred to advance
their own race alone away from any
interference
they did however keep brown up clean of
debris out of respect
and as a memorial to the creators that
were killed there they spent their time
working on creating a mainframe that
could house the programs of every single
geth unit
a goal that they'd been working towards
for a couple of hundred years
however the reaper sovereign approached
the geth and offered them
advanced technology that they could use
in turn for their assistance
only a few took up sovereign's offer to
serve and were then called heretics by
the remaining geth
who wanted to create their project with
their own technology
and were suspicious of the reapers
calling them the old machines
the reapers despite obtaining a new
workforce were repulsed by the devotion
shown by the geth
who praised the reapers as being the
pinnacle of a.i evolution
these geth left the main geth network
and followed sovereign and his
right-hand man
sarin across the galaxy which is where
we meet them at the start of the first
mass effect game
if you're picking up mass effect for the
first time with the legendary edition or
you're just revisiting it after a few
years away
hopefully this video has helped you
understand the quarian geth conflict
better
we've got more lore videos up on the
channel right now including ones on the
krogan and the genophage
as well as the protheans and for more
mass effect make sure to subscribe
we'll catch you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you